elionji here is worried there's a
shortage of fertilizer in kenya he says
a bag that used to cost twenty dollars
is now around sixty that's too expensive
for many farmers here they are going to
go in hunger
because there is nothing
because there is no food in food
there is no no harvest in there in the
gardens
so they are going to go hunger
there is a there is going to be farming
in this place
one of his neighbors frederick muyrory
is in trouble his beans have failed he
says he couldn't afford fertilizer
i might have to give up on farming
something i have done all my life
but it is not working
fertilizer which provides the nutrients
needed to help crops grow is in short
supply around the world several african
countries depend on imports which before
the war used to come from russia and
ukraine food production is most at risk
in developing nations where many farmers
may not have the financial resources to
deal with the crisis in some countries
some farmers are using more manure to
nourish their crops
but farmers here say using only manure
is not enough the plants also need the
potassium phosphorus and nitrogen from
fertilizers to grow bigger faster and to
produce more food
prices of animal feed are also rising
sometimes there is government subsidised
fertilizer but it's in short supply this
is a crisis where
the supply of the raw materials are not
available
uh
definitely
we don't know how long it may take
and this is the situation
all over
we don't know how long so we are just
praying to god that
it is shortened
so that we come back to normal
it's frustrating funji here who's been
farming for 30 years he says working the
land has never been this hard haru
mutasa al jazeera kiamba county kenya